je pense qu'il faut des crises créé la
société française il faut l'apaiser
comment pour l'apaiser pour l'apaiser
c'est simple ils font il ne faut pas
opposer les uns aux autres il faut
vraiment convaincre et moi ce sera mon
mode de présidence je veux convaincre
les français je veux les emmener je
pouvais marquer
quand il dit je vais emmerder et non
vaccinés y crise quand il dit les non
vaccinés ce non pas des citoyens ils les
crises et donc ça provoque moi je crois
qu'il ya une autre gouvernance qui est
possible on emmène tout le peuple
français avec soin avec autorité avec
évidemment autoriés parce qu'à un moment
il faut décider à un moment donné faut
retenir c'est que j'ai fait les réformes
difficiles je sais ce qu'il sait ça veut
dire tenir mais on fait avec le peuple
français passant lui pas une
hyperprésidence
une présidente qui a pas la main qui te
rend qui décide mais qui avant décidé
écoute qui s'est passé lundi et quand
même sidérant on a un président candidat
en réalité un candidat emmanuel macron
qui vient à nice avec les moyens de
l'état avec les moyens du contribuable
donc en grand équipage comme on dit en
jet de présidente et c'était pour
annoncer un programme présidentiel à
horizon 2030 alors ça c'est scandaleux
et nous nous faisons campagne avec nos
moyens qui sont modestes et si vous
comptez combien d'haïtiens dès qu'on ne
constate espérer que ce déplacement soit
réintégré avec candidat mais ben ali
masque voilà emmanuel macron est
candidat il nous propose il nous fait
des propositions ont d'ailleurs un peu
gazeuse sur la sécurité à horizon 2030
c'est pas un président de la république
qu'on a vu à nice lundi d'ailleurs cette
étape assez ironique il venait poser la
première pierre d'un commissariat qui
n'aura son permis de construire que dans
un an vous voyez c'était bien un
un pardon un déplacement de candidat sur
la sécurité qui est le poulet les
manuels macro aujourd'hui parce que nous
avons une insécurité croissante 32% de
violence en plus pendant le quinquennat
32% c'est ça le bilan des manuels macro
qu'il essaye de faire oublier cette
année